حتى مع وجود المجهر ،
يمكن أن يكون العثور على الجراثيم أو البكتيريا أمرًا صعبًا بالنسبة لمعظم
الجراثيم ، 99 ليست ضارة في الواقع ،
بعضها مفيد لك في الواقع ، لكن واحد في
المائة من الجراثيم يمكن أن يصيبك بالمرض
ويمكن أن يكون أي شيء من نزلات
البرد إلى الحياة  - تهدد الأمراض
بينما قد يبدو الحمام وكأنه أكبر
ملاذ للجراثيم ، فهناك بالفعل غرفة أخرى يجب
أن تفكر فيها في
مطبخك لأنه يمكننا
شطف بعض اللحوم النيئة في
مغسلة المطبخ ، ونشطف التربة من
الخضروات الجذرية في حوض المطبخ
ونترك الأطباق أيضًا  مع الطعام في
بعض الأحيان حتى بين عشية وضحاها ، يقوم الكثير من
الأشخاص بتقطيع اللحوم النيئة على لوح التقطيع
ثم استخدام نفس لوح التقطيع
للخضروات ، لذلك يستخدم الكثير من الناس
الإسفنج لأطباقهم ولكن بعد ذلك يستخدمون
نفس الإسفنجة لمسح العدادات
وتغرق و  ما عليك سوى نقل البكتيريا
والجراثيم ذهابًا وإيابًا ، فكيف
نحصل على تلك الجراثيم للبقاء بعيدًا ،
والأهم هو غسل يديك
والجزء الثاني هو الحفاظ على
نظافة الأسطح  والثالث هو فقط أن
تضع في اعتبارك كيفية انتشار الجراثيم ، فقد
تحتاج إلى لوح تقطيع مخصص للحوم النيئة
وآخر للخضروات ،
قد ترغب في إسفنجة مخصصة
للكونترتوب واستخدام إسفنجة مختلفة
للأطباق للصحة دقيقة أنا آدم  مكوي